Guys, before this video begins, I want
to encourage you in these very important
days, the days
of to give charity to the Norwegian
masid which we together have raised so
much money for just like many other
projects which we together have raised
so much money more millions of pounds
probably altogether across the years and
it's been a fantastic thing that we've
done that. But we need to be able to do
that in these times because the prophet
Muhammad wasallam said that there are no
days in which good deeds are better than
these 10 days. The 10 days of this is
authentic hadith and they
says not even going to fight in the way
of Allah. They
said that's what he said except for a
man that goes and basically gets martyed
in the in the way. So imagine now giving
charity in this time. It experiates your
sins. It raises your level. wall. You
will regret it if you don't give to such
a noble and honorable cause as this one.
Click the
[Music]
link. How are you guys doing? There's a
man called Charlie Kirk who's an
activist, a supposed
activist, a high school dropout, and an
ultra critarian who's been getting
involved in subjects that are way beyond
his pay grade. An individual who is a
right-wing, not just a right-wing apple
polisher, but a Donald Trump apple
polisher. an individual who've been
stuck in the plantation, the ideological
plantation of MAGA, picking the
political cotton for Trump, being
whipped by Daddy Trump into political
and ideological submission, who came to
the United Kingdom and instead of
engaging with his
adversaries in a manner that would befit
someone who claims or at least acts like
a debater has done the same thing as Ben
Shapiro, another coward, another weasel
who's been weasling around and running
away because he is a
pussanimous from me for many, many
years. And this individual
here has come to University of Cambridge
speaking to students just like Ben
Shapiro does the same format exactly.
And even then when he interacts with
students he thinks he's making all these
fantastic points but I've never seen a
person who makes so many
blunders in such a short span of time.
Let's take a look at just one video and
come back and respond in kind. Let's say
Hamas was like eradicated. What what do
you think should happen between both the
communities in order to bring I guess
peace between both of them and make
things better? Yeah. So, just so
everyone's clear, the reason why Gaza is
under Hamas control is that there was a
peace deal that was signed. Israel got
out of Gaza in the pursuit of peace.
Israel gave up the Sinai in pursuit of
peace. Israel gave up portions of the
West Bank in pursuit of peace. Israel
has actually decreased the land size of
their nation significantly in the last
40 years. This man has made about four
or five points and actually every single
one of them is false. He says that there
was a peace treaty that was signed in
2005 supposedly between Hamas or some
other entity that was there at the time
and let's say the Israeli authorities
because otherwise it wouldn't be a peace
treaty. But actually this is incorrect.
is factually incorrect because it was a
unilateral disengagement that took place
at the time of Ariel Chiron and in fact
it was a decision that was made to
remove settlers who were there in
Gaza from the Gaza Strip. It doesn't
actually mean that Israel at that point
had lost what is referred to in
international law as effective military
control. They still had and still have
effective military control because they
controlled what was going into Gaza and
what was leaving Gaza. They controlled
the airspace, the the waters, etc., etc.
And so they had effective military
control. The second thing he mentioned
is the Sinai Peninsula. And of course,
this is a very strange thing to mention
because it's going back in time now to
the conflict with Egypt. And the
question to be asked is at what point
did the United Nations from the
inception of the so-called state of
Israel in
1948 include the Sinai Peninsula within
the perimeters of what is now referred
to as proper Israel. That's never been
the case. In fact, there was an illegal
invasion by the Israelis into sovereign
Egyptian land, which was redeemed
thereafter by the Camp David agreement
in 1978 after the well-known war in
1973. And Anas Hadat, the then president
of Egypt, was
negotiating on behalf of that country to
get that particular um peninsula back.
So that's incorrect. You're saying that
they gave it up in the pursuit of peace.
That's they took it in the pursuit of
expansionism in the first place and they
did so against the agreements and the
borders set by the UN even which we
don't even consider to be correct
borders for many reasons which we can
speak about afterwards. And then he says
the West Bank. Now I want to know in
your mind why you think the West Bank in
any way, shape or form belongs to
Israel. The West Bank is not a territory
that belongs to Israel. The West Bank is
part of the Palestinian
territories. So you're saying they gave
something back which didn't belong to
them in the first place. Of course, you
can say the same thing about the
entire region. Actually the whole thing
was a sham because of the Balffor
declaration that England or Britain I
should say which was a country a foreign
country promising the land of one people
to another
people. Weren't you the same patriot
that was talking about America? Would
you accept that for America? You
wouldn't accept that for America and you
like the rest of the MAGA surviile
submissive
slaves would inc would celebrate the
independence of the United States from
the United Kingdom. And in fact, in one
recent video that he put out, he said
that he came to to London and then he
was so appalled with what he saw. He
didn't spell out exactly what he was
appalled with that he basically fell
into prostration almost and kissed the
floor when he when he came to United
States. I don't know exactly where did
you go in the United States. Did you go
to Detroit? Did you go to the shanty
towns of Chicago? Did you go to the hill
billy areas where probably your parents
are from and your friends are there and
the rednecks that your your compatriots
and your friends? Did you go to those
areas a little shotgun there and this
and that? Huh? Did you go to those areas
and then bow down like that? Or did you
go to the areas where people were
getting shot up or homeless people were
needing uh your assistance? Which area
of America did you go to exactly? Or did
you go to the metro system which is one
of the worst metro systems in any
western country in New York? Did you go
to that one? Where exactly in America
did you feel like you were in such a
utopian place comparative to the United
Kingdom? I think you're living a
utopian delusion actually. But putting
that to the side, what I'm going to say
to you is this. You've been running away
for too long. You're trying your best to
manufacture scenarios just like Ben
Shapiro where in which you can
antagonize, provoke, debate, and control
all the variables of a debate with
undergraduate students. The only thing
that they have in common with you is the
fact that both of you haven't graduated
yet. In fact, at least they are trying
to. You dropped out. But that's another
issue for another day. Why not debate
somebody who's established in the
issues? I challenge you. You coward,
bucktooth coward, hillbilly coward, maga
coward. Come. And although that you're
unqualified and you have no expertise in
the area and you're a nobody when it
comes to Islam, the religion you're
speaking about, you're an absolute
nobody when it comes to Gaza. You have
no formal qualifications, no expertise,
nothing. I don't mind putting you under
my foot just like you're happy for daddy
Donald Trump. Daddy did it. Donald
Trump to
put you under his foot, his MAGA foot,
and whip you and the rest of the MAGA
boys into
submission. That's all I have to say,
you coward. And if you have the bravery
for it, I'm ready. And that's all I have
to say.